I just love the idea of making a world.
It's an art, but it's also a craft.
I've always been interested in
history and politics and how that informs
what we do, how we think,
what we wear.
Everything is interesting and informative
to what people wear or wore.
My job is to
help translate the director
and the actor's vision for the character
and kind of help tell the story.
And also help the audience understand
who the person is, where they are in time.
There are the homages to
Wong Kar-wai
In the Mood for Love.
But also references Michelle Yeoh,
the actress.
She had suggested some brands that
she liked, and one of them was Elie Saab.
They had graciously sent some
dresses for us to borrow.
The one that we see is the one that
we thought worked the best for the scene.
We did submerse a lot
of clothing in the water.
We needed to be honest about what
happens when things
are in the water and how do they move.
So we informed VFX.
It wasn't VFX informing us,
it was the other way around.
It started out as a concept of red.
It was a work in progress
and it took us about six prototypes,
but eventually we narrowed it down.
Everybody keeps on saying it's a
dress and it's not a dress.
I call it a playsuit and it's shorts.
The idea was that it was Nellie’s.
She had very little money at the time.
In my mind, she cobbled it together.
If you have good costumes,
you should be able
to read more into it than just
that person is wearing a red shirt.
You should be able to feel who the
person is and where you are.